era muy bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de france 24 en esta
oportunidad nos acompaña ingrid
betancourt candidata a la presidencia de
colombia por el partido verde oxígeno
para los comicios que se llevarán a cabo
el próximo 29 de mayo hablamos de una de
las figuras más reconocidas de la escena
política colombiana fue senadora y esta
es la segunda vez que aspira al máximo
cargo político del país primero lo hizo
en el año 2002 verdad ingrid año que
marcó definitivamente su vida al ser
lamentablemente secuestrada por la
extinta guerrilla de las farc que le
manda mantuvo en cautiverio durante un
poco más de seis años ingrid betancourt
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
prada mítico esto es un placer que esté
con nosotros es para mí un gran momento
estar acá compartiendo con ustedes
bueno hay un grid transcurrieron 20 años
entre sus dos candidaturas
presidenciales la coyuntura por supuesto
ha cambiado muchísimo pero cuál es su
visión del país que comparte y que la
distancia de aquella ingrid del año 2002
pues vamos a empezar adelante coyuntura
estamos frente a una invasión de rusia a
ucrania y mi preocupación es obviamente
por los colombianos que están allá yo
acabo de hablar con el ministro de
defensa con diego molano primero para
agradecerle porque ayer se conmemoraba
pues en estas semanas estuvo
conmemorando los 20 años de mi secuestro
estuve en la zona pudimos llegar al
lugar de ese puesto en toda la
tranquilidad a pesar del paro armado
total protección de la policía agradezco
a la policía y de la fuerza militar
agradezco al batallón liborio mejía pero
pero en este momento cuando hablé con él
fue para pedirle que hiciéramos lo
necesario para repatriar a aquellos
colombianos que en este momento se
encuentran en ucrania en situación de
riesgo se sabe que las fronteras siguen
abiertas pero obviamente hay problemas
de papeles muchas veces para los
colombianos de poder transitar de un
país a otro necesitamos darle seguridad
gracias sangre por este mensaje en este
contexto de absoluta tensión no por el
conflicto entre rusia y ucrania la
reiteró ahora si ingrid la pregunta
veinte años pasaron entre estas dos
candidaturas y aspiraciones a la
presidencia obviamente la coyuntura como
si ha cambiado y bastante no solo en
colombia en todo el mundo respecto de su
visión del país que comparte con aquella
ingrid del año 2012 y que la distancia
comparto la voluntad de cambiar a
colombia de lograr derrotar a los
corruptos a las maquinarias el mismo
tema que era mi bandera del 2002 vuelve
a ser el mismo tema del 2022 hoy y la
corrupción sigue infiltrando las
campañas tuve que romper con la
coalición de centro esperanza porque
después de haber acordado tener unos
principios para no aceptar maquinarias
es decir corrupción electoral dentro de
este espacio de coalición entró un
candidato con
apoyos de maquinarias y obviamente esto
es una trampa que se le hace a los
colombianos y en especial a la coalición
lamentó que ellos se hayan acomodado que
no hayan tomado las distancias pero creo
que para colombia como en el 2012 es muy
importante que entendamos que la
corrupción no es un problema moral es un
problema económico es un problema social
es un problema de estado es un problema
de vidas que quedan truncadas por el
efecto la corrupción ahora que ha
cambiado pues he cambiado yo 20 años más
vieja también esto quiere decir con una
visión digamos más global con una un
convencimiento de que ya no podemos
postergar lo que en ese momento también
era una bandera nuestra pero hoy la
urgencia del cambio climático nos hace
pensar que colombia tiene que ser verde
completamente verde exportadora de verde
y en particular de créditos de carbono
que eso es algo sobre lo cual voy a
trabajar para darle a los colombianos y
en particular a aquellos que viven en
zonas agrícolas con problemas de
violencia u otro tipo de salidas
económicas y el tema internacional es
decir colombia tiene que entrar a acabar
con el narcotráfico esto es una decisión
que no puede ser solamente de colombia
tenemos que despenalizar se tiene que
hacer en todo el continente para eso
necesitamos aliados es decir que
necesitamos una visión en que colombia
no se cierre a sí misma no sé
no no no se vuelva a un euro a proteger
y es algo algunos candidatos están
ofreciendo una colombia que vuelva al
pasado en cerrándose sobre sí misma yo
quiero abrir a colombia al futuro y al
mundo
ingrid bueno como decía al comienzo de
la entrevista entre estos 20 años usted
estuvo 6 es secuestrada por la extinta
guerrilla de las farc osa usted ha
vivido el conflicto armado de una manera
muy particular lamentablemente no muy
cercana le ha tocado en carne propia
esto digamos la diferencia de otros
candidatos en este sentido quisiera
preguntarle cómo encarar y a lo que es
la implementación de los acuerdos de paz
hacia donde lo dirigiría usted si es una
buena pregunta porque yo creo que soy la
única que realmente sé de qué hablo en
carne propia cuando hablo de guerra
ahora la guerra la hacen
mayoritariamente los hombres pero pagan
el precio a las mujeres por lo tanto
para mí la consola consolidación del
proceso de paz es también un proceso de
género vamos a trabajar para darle en
particular a las lideresas que están
siendo afectadas zonas de conflicto
mayor protección esto es obviamente un
tema de pie de fuerza pero también es un
tema de inteligencia militar para
proteger a todos estos actores que son
los que en realidad están impidiendo que
las organizaciones delictivas amplíen su
espacio territorial
vamos a fortalecer institucionalmente
las instituciones de la paz en
particular la red ustedes saben que en
2028 se acaba la gente pero son muchos
los procesos hay gente que en este
momento está durmiendo en frente de la
gente para poder que sus procesos sean
mirados con urgencia queremos darle
tranquilidad a los colombianos a las
víctimas decirle que todos los procesos
que entraron a la red van a tener una
sentencia van a salir juzgados y para
ello vamos a tener que extender los
plazos y finalmente vamos a hacer yo
creo algo que es muy importante y es
restablecer la verdad tenemos una
comisión que es la comisión de la verdad
no queremos que esta comisión sea una
comisión de registro queremos que sea
una comisión de análisis es decir que
realmente después de todas las
testimonios que logre recuperar la
comisión de la verdad
haga una auditoría y se le permita a
esta comisión de una manera neutral pero
también con poder de digamos de análisis
decirle a los colombianos quiénes son
los que han dicho toda la verdad quiénes
son los que han dicho la mitad de la
verdad y quiénes son los que
definitivamente las versiones no
concuerdan una deuda así con con la
verdad la memoria y la justicia en grid
habla usted no de la situación en la que
se encuentran muchas ligerezas sociales
y bueno quisiera preguntarle cómo
gestionaría no la violencia actual en
colombia una violencia que viene desde
varios frentes no tenemos por un lado
como decíamos no lo que es el aumento
del asesinato de líderes y lideresas
sociales por otro lado están también las
fuerzas de seguridad en la mira ejemplo
de esto ha sido el estación social del
año pasado que dejó decenas de
manifestantes muertos las cifras varían
según las fuentes también incluso
denuncias de abuso sexual cometidas por
uniformados
encararía usted una reforma de las
fuerzas si bueno se está sobre la mesa
esto ya es impostergable pero yo no
quiero hacer nada contra las fuerzas
sino con las fuerzas y lo digo porque
también en este espacio de polarización
del país es muy fácil atacar a los
soldados atacar a los policías
desconociendo la realidad que vive en
ellos en in situ es decir realmente
muchas veces sin mayor apoyo y teniendo
que enfrentar en situaciones muy
delicadas ahora y para mí uno de los
planes centrales lo repito es la
corrupción cuando nosotros vamos a las
regiones y vemos que hay pie de fuerza
pero que ese pie de fuerza
no da como resultado la protección de
los ciudadanos nos tenemos que preguntar
qué está pasando muchas veces los
habitantes nos dicen que los comandantes
tienen acuerdos oscuros con cabecillas o
de las disidencias o de la ln o de los
grupos de narcotráfico es decir que
definitivamente si nosotros queremos que
la presencia de la fuerza pública dé
resultados necesitamos que la línea de
mando desde arriba hasta abajo sea una
línea sin corrupción ese es un primer
punto el segundo punto que para nosotros
es muy importante
cuando nosotros hablamos de seguridad no
estamos hablando solamente de pie de
fuerza estamos hablando de inteligencia
de inteligencia que es militar que es
inteligencia civil que es poner todos
los organismos que puedan tener
inteligencia a trabajar juntos para
proteger a nuestra población y tercero
como siempre es el problema social y
económico tenemos que llegar de manera
integral el estado tiene que llegar con
sus escuelas con sus puestos de salud
con sus vías y con la comunicación
internet para que sus estas comunidades
puedan también expresarse y dar a
conocer lo que les está sucediendo a
nivel de la nación por lo tanto esta es
una visión integral y es una visión de
mujer la visión de mujeres que nosotros
sabemos que las mujeres somos las
mayores víctimas del conflicto tenemos
que proteger a la mujer tenemos que
empoderar la titulación de tierras
especialmente y en prioridad para las
mujeres trabajo para las mujeres pero no
en términos de regalos sino con créditos
subsidiados que le permitan a ellas
emprender cumplir sus sueños y vivienda
se sabe que el gran problema cuando yo
hablo las mujeres en colombia cada vez
que les pregunto qué es lo que más
necesitan me dicen una vivienda una
casita porque porque ellas trabajan
mayoritariamente el sector informal lo
que gana es es sólo para pagar arriendo
y no le dejan nada a sus hijos y la
mujer quiere dejarle algo a sus hijos y
yo quiero dejarle algo a mi familia
extendida que es con hombre
y leemos un poco más bueno como hablamos
previamente al menciona entrevista de
los vínculos de colombia con el resto
del mundo no a nivel diplomático durante
un eventual gobierno suyo cómo abordaría
los vínculos con venezuela usted se ha
manifestado proclive a lo que sería
quizás un restablecimiento de los
vínculos esto implica quizás dejar de
reconocer a juan guaidó como presidente
del país como hizo iván duque bueno yo
creo que ese es un tema que tenemos que
enfocar por otro lado en el tema de las
relaciones con venezuela tiene que pasar
con el actor que en este momento estaba
fungiendo de presidente de venezuela y
todas las críticas las podemos hacer
pero para nosotros eso es condicionado
condicionado al problema que le atañe a
colombia que es que se resguardan tras
la frontera venezolana las disidencias
de las farc el ln y también el
narcotráfico nosotros estamos
condicionando a un restablecimiento de
las relaciones a que el presidente de
régimen es decir nicolás maduro entregue
las cabecillas de estas organizaciones
las extradición a colombia y después
comenzamos a hablar
y ahora vamos a ver quizás un poquito
álgido no algo por lo que usted ha sido
criticada y al día de hoy también lo es
por algunos sectores por supuesto no por
todos tiene que ver con aquel reclamo
que hizo al estado colombiano en el año
2010 que tenía que ver con una suerte de
pidió de indemnización no una cifra
cercana a los 6.8 millones de dólares
por los perjuicios recibidos no ven
términos morales económicos tras haber
sido secuestrada por la ex caricia de
las farc usted desistió de esa acción no
obstante hay sectores que la siguen
criticando cree que al día de hoy sigue
pagando un costo quizás político por lo
menos por aquello bueno eso es pedagogía
que tenemos que hacer en colombia en
colombia en la guerra
condicionó las mentalidades e hizo que
las víctimas se vieran como culpables
culpables de estar en el sitio que no
correspondía de dar expresión colombiana
papaya es decir de permitir ser agredido
culpables también de reclamar nuestros
derechos y de defendernos y yo considero
que mi caso es 1 entre 51 millones de
colombianos que han sido secuestrados
por el sistema de corrupción y de
violencia que tiene colombia yo quiero
que se establezca un derecho para todos
los colombianos de ser compensados la
compensación es muy importante para
cualquier víctima hay 51 millones de
víctimas en colombia todos merecemos ser
compensados esa es mi política
inglés bueno nos queda alrededor de un
minuto pero no quiero dejar de hacerle
la siguiente pregunta ya lo mencionó
durante esta entrevista usted es
partidaria de la despenalización no de
las drogas como encarar este tema en un
país como colombiano uno de los peces de
mayor producción de cocaína de todo el
mundo tengo un tema con el que va
tendría que lidiar con grupos de
narcotráfico sectores que conviven con
ellos
de productor de cocaína sino consumidor
es que ya colombia pasa a ser un país
que exporta pero que también consume y
por eso es muy importante que hablemos
de la alianza para el progreso un
acuerdo regional de canadá hasta la
patagonia de manera que podamos
despenalizar regionalmente la droga para
que ese negocio se acabe en toda la
región acabamos la guerra contra las
drogas quiere decir que esos recursos
que hemos venido malgastando porque no
nos pueden 40 años la guerra contra las
drogas ha sido un fracaso esos recursos
los vamos a invertir en nuestros
campesinos aquellos que en ese momento
son las víctimas del narcotráfico las
víctimas de la violencia pero también
las víctimas del cambio climático esto
va a generar migración en todo el
continente podemos
y matar dos pájaros de un tiro' acabar
con el negocio del narcotráfico y al
mismo tiempo darle seguridad a nuestros
campesinos para que no migren
ingrediente tan cursi nos ha pasado
volando el tiempo lamentablemente le
agradecemos muchísimo su presencia en
france 24 gracias a ustedes gracias a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a que sigan informando se en
el resto de nuestra programación y
también en france mit y cuatro.com sigan
con nosotros
[Música]